welcome to this video playing saman
international master sama gido capriole
okay i am from Italy let's see italian
game i wanted to it is funny why should
I have played Italian game against ago
from Italy okay let's see I just wanted
to do something different is there some
interesting way to play here maybe
without castling like here it may be
completely five he can and he does okay
the k it seems that this is at least a
an online he's playing us playing this
quite quite confidently and quickly okay
interesting so okay
yeah he's playing instantly all the time
it seems how do I continue now and i
wonder if i should go even quincy for
him maybe maybe not sure that before
lets me anything and maybe I can do
something in this end game if you take
some in there's still this knight on c6
slightly misplaced and hereby I at least
I have the king in the in the game
already it can never be a be great for
white that that's clear but maybe I can
can can do something okay if I go 83 he
can take bishop as well so yeah maybe I
need to cover this no but I can it's not
a big deal he has to retreat now anyway
so
yeah just in nothing position but ok I'm
going to going to play this anyway try
to do something in the end game night to
see form yeah maybe i can trade one pair
of brooks and then maybe try to get the
night to see form and then f3m night f5
yeah i think i like the pollution it's
it's it's of course very very unexcited
but I have a very slight pull here very
slide but it is down before I should
probably do this at some point anyway
lend some reliable project protection to
the pawn what is my Knights doing here
maybe night I can go to d2 we are winner
winner little temple hmm alrighty 325
would be nice maybe I should okay I can
do this first winning this temple and
then night everyone to e3 maybe he maybe
maybe he has bishop I'm sorry night 96 I
wonder if it is an idea to play Bishop
e3 even to trade this it's a bit
unconventional but maybe okay
let's let's do this first
night to d6 but I have 93 m then with 95
in the mix we are no definitely get in
this I wonder should I keep both nights
maybe i don't i'm not sure about this
rookie hell I have this Knight to g5
ideas on like here I can now give this
check check
d 6 f 6 is hanging right
and but is it good to take I don't think
so really no no I'm threatening Knight
f6 again and he's also tied to see seven
so we would take now and 93
I thought this might be something
because of this week pawn time warning
hmm 97
interesting going to inform if he moves
is neither unite f5
hmm
check here
well here you know him I grip this pawn
you five is hanging check I know he's
getting to getting this Oh trick him
check
nah no no and cannot stop this ah I
cannot stop the porn I'm all silly was
that after this game where he was just
worse all the time I know okay white
reasons yeah I mean okay it wasn't much
worse but I mean all this it's just snow
justjust good for why this end game yeah
see I am but the good old time night if
a twins 9 f8 wins quite easily this
somehow it doesn't because f34 down and
now them now it's very very tricky
already with the little time night if
aid again but I simply didn't see 95 it
was stupid yeah and here well gee for
him is a little bit of a fancy move I
can just take him I should take just
take this this and like basically can
give up no f four faults with no counter
play yeah that's easy there the whole
time it was like very little but I had a
slight pool I really had here here so he
be five is good hi interesting
interesting jack Luke g8 yeah my other
good end came yeah it was always very
very little but there are these kind of
end games it sometimes can be a bit
deceiving one problem is that this
knight on c6 is always not well placed
it looks at protected squares and
like has very little in terms of in
terms of activity of course it's very
very solid and term and Tommy he can can
equalize but it's always a little bit of
something but very stupid that I lost it
in the end even okay thanks for watching